thank you
for having me my name is alvaro videla
i'm
from uruguay and i work as an engineer
at
fauna.com it's a new database i know sql
database
please visit the the website so my
manager knows i'm here
i wrote this article last year i got
over 100 000
visitors basically explaining my story
on how i got into programming
10 years ago i was basically selling
food in the streets in the countryside
of uruguay
but about this talk is called metaphors
we compute by and you can read it
on the acm q website for example and
also on the
communications of the acm
so the year is 1980 one year earlier
from me being born
and there is a book published called
metaphors we live by
so you can tell already that the title
of my talk is nothing
original it's just a copy of that thing
because
this work was so influential that after
it came metaphors we
socialized by metaphors we i don't know
what buy so
this work by lack of an and johnson the
idea
was to study the brain because they were
cognitive scientists
but you cannot literally go and open
people's brains and see what's there
inside that's kind of illegal
it tends to be so they say okay let's
try to understand the brain by using a
proxy which is language
and they find out that metaphor isn't
just a matter of uh
poetry uh like rhetorical flourish
like metaphors actually they dictate
the way we think how we behave
how we perceive and how our conceptual
system is built
to give you an example which is the
first from the book
uh they say argument is war
war is a metaphor in which we frame
arguments
i think this is kinda in line with the
previous talk
why people have all these frameworks on
on the internet
because if we think of arguments as war
we will say things like your claims
are indefensible he attacks every weak
point in my argument
i demolished his argument i never won an
argument with him
or he his criticisms were right on
targets
the point being because of this framing
of argent
as a as a war will literally try to
destroy the other person
and they ask lack of in this book as
like
what if argument will be dance which
kind of
metaphor will be using and then thinking
about
uh argument because if it's dance we
need to collaborate together to reach
a common goal and then maybe a metaphor
will be you shouldn't be stepping on my
toes or something like that
but it will be a more collaborative
thing
but i can see your faces that you are
still not convinced
and when people is not convinced we talk
about politics right
and there was a really nice article from
the bbc
called how metaphors shape women's lives
but it talked about all this
glass ceiling metaphor and whatnot like
how you are stopped from progressing at
companies
but for me even more interested in that
article was this research
that was done where they grab a group of
students
and they tell them that there is a wild
beast
praying on the city like crime is a wild
beast praying on the city and to the
other group
they tell them that virus is infecting
the city
both groups get the same data the same
statistics and so on
they have a different framing metaphor
when people is asked
um
what are the solutions they propose 70
75 percent of the beast students
they wanted to put people in jail and do
very strong uh
punishment and the people in the virus
case wanted to help the other helper
help them improve progress and so on
so when they asked them like why do you
choose that kind of punishment or what
you want to
help people get better and so on they
say because the
data say so none of them realize they
were primed with a particular
metaphor there is also a book from the
80s by judy
weichmann it's called feminism confronts
technology and it's really good if you
want to
have a deep dive into a feminism point
of view
from into technology and it's like how
the words
hard and soft have been changing across
the history of technology
like at some point the intellectual work
wasn't considered
interesting or whatever so all the
machos out there
did this work soft but suddenly we had
computers
and we could dominate the world with
computers so all this macho mentality
brought the hard
work into the into programming with all
these very aggressive
metaphors like you need to be you need
to be calling
uh 24 7. you need to be pushing
for that release and all this thing like
about your stamina and so on
and they and she says no matter how
masculinity is defined
according to this ever adaptable
ideology
it always constructs women as ill-suited
to technology
technological pursuits so
language is also important even in how
we
approach different groups if you want to
make for example technology
friendlier for women or friendly for
other groups like in latin america for
example
so still not convinced
human resource management
if you think with this metaphor you will
think that
the same way you replace a hard drive on
a server you replace
a programmer on your team and there are
many managers that think
uh this way but we need to understand
that people
are not resources like we are not here
thanks
we bring more to the to the wheel than
just a thing that can be replaced
we we build uh interpersonal
relationships
uh we organize uh things to happen in
certain times and so on i mean we are
very rich living beings not just a
resource and i can just replace
and finally trigger warning
about giving platform to racist people
there is a conference
in the united states i won't name them
that they like to have uh keynoters uh
like racist people last year the
keynoter was one that considered women
to be
inferior and so on when they when the
community came against this
this uh conference and they criticized
them for having a racist person as a
keynoter
they wrote a blog post and this blog
post was called
wrestling with inclusion at whatever the
name of that
conf um
and i wonder wrestling why do you need
to wrestle with
with inclusion what can you just have a
dialogue what can you talk
with people involved in these
communities no they decided to wrestle
very i'm gonna beat you down
right but i guess you're here
to talk about computers right
so computers have you seen the movie
hidden figures where these astronauts
from the states this uh
the black women helped put a man
an american in space the russians had
done that already
um
they were doing calculation they were
doing com computing
by hand so this remember called
computers
but at some point we had this very fast
machine electronic
machine that um
was doing what they were doing really
fast so how do we call
those things that do what these people
is already doing okay
automatic computers the automatic world
was dropped in history
and now we just call them computers
and why is this because metaphors
they enable understanding when we don't
know how to talk about something
we probably will use some sort of
metaphor
i don't remember yesterday if you give
me a second
i was watching
a talk here about this guy that made
a simulator for colorblind people and
things like that
and he said addition
additional screen real estate that you
need to account for
so now there is a real state that we
account for
this is completely metaphorical way of
of
of understanding what is going on that
just the screen is bigger and we need to
do something with that bigger screen
but when i say that metaphors enable
understanding
the typical metaphor is from
shakespeare that says juliet is like
the sun and we need to understand that
metaphors
aren't a one-to-one mapping between
source domain and target domain
metaphors they just illuminate some
areas so we
understand what what is meant what
juliet
means for romeo in this case like his
life depends on her he revolves around
her
all day or he thought or whatever she's
the light of his life
but we don't think juliet gave me skin
cancer
because we are smart enough to
understand that metaphors are like
one-to-one mapping like
juliet is an atomic bomb
walking around italy right
there is a book by a guy i think
from either the netherlands or belgium
peter garden force
which is called the geometry of meaning
semantics based on conceptual spaces
long story short somebody got paid in
europe for doing
uh geometric geometrical research
of language these things in south
america don't happen
we try to make sure that all cows make
better meat basically
anyway in that book it's really really
interesting because
he said that metaphorical mappings
preserve the cognitive topology of the
source domain
in a way that is consistent with the
inherent structure of the target domain
so source sun target
juliet metaphors transfer
information from one conceptual domain
to another
and what is transfer is a pattern rather
than domain specific information
juliet is not giving you cancer and a
metaphor can thus be used to identify a
structure in a domain
that will not have been discovered
otherwise
so that is the power that metaphors
bring us when we need to understand how
the world actually works
and for me i stole this animation from
from that link down there this is what
we are doing
in a way with our brain with metaphors
we are doing like a graphic is a more
efficient problem that we solve
constantly
when we are able to apply a metaphor in
a context that has nothing to do with it
this is how metaphors create new
knowledge
but the problem with metaphors is that
they also obscure understanding
back in the 18th century when they tried
to create the telegraph
the metaphor was far
writing tele graph and because of
of this metaphor they were so tied to
the metaphor that they really wanted to
create a device that will kind of write
remotely instead of having something
like morse code or whatever
because morse code was not a thing uh
thanks to rylan and then more scanda so
that you could
start encoding on language our language
in a different code
that is not the one that we use for
speaking
humanity realize like okay we can
transmit this
that we talk in a different way before
moscow before telegraph
we weren't into we hadn't realized as a
species or society that we could do
these things
with language
and nicolas carr in this book uh the
shadows
says that sometimes our tools do what we
tell them to
but other times we adapt ourselves to
our tools requirements
and we need to be careful with this like
we are today adapted to the
to having a phone and twitter every day
let's say
or back in the day when people invented
this
in switzerland i'm pretty sure it wasn't
not invented in switzerland but
i live in switzerland i need to say
these kind of things
so before people didn't leave by the
second or by the minute whenever the
church bell rang before the
going to mass or whatever the news they
have to gather
at the town square or something like
that but it wasn't like
they were clocking every single thing
and this is also for example i thought i
learned in london like this is why they
know the exact locations
when jack the reaper was doing things
because there are so many churches in
london that they were hearing the bells
so after this many bills was that jack
the reaper did something somewhere
so that was a way of of tracking time
back then today we are totally adapted
to having this super precise information
back to the talk uh metaphors
are the tools of thought so going back
to the beginning of the talk
depending on the metaphors we use is how
we understand
the world around us and also
how we can understand a code
there is a paper that nobody knows who
wrote it because this was
scanned from donald newt archives
and not even newt knows who wrote this
paper
and for me it's like the best unknown
paper is from back in the
60s if i'm not mistaken and they say
to program is to write to another
programmer
about our solution to a problem so
programming is
forget about the computer the computer
is just a tool
what we are doing with programs is
communicating
ideas communicating solutions and as i
said also in the structure and
interpretation of computer programs
programs must be written for people to
read and
only incidentally for machines to
execute
and this is not something new if we go
back to the
1955-54 david
wheeler from england he invented the
subroutine
because that's what people do in england
like the invention routines they invent
computers stuff like that
but anyway at the end of the paper
he says that there is no need for the
subroutine when you have like assembler
code
because he says the above remarks may be
summarized by saying subroutines are
very useful
although not absolutely necessary and
that the primary objectives to be born
in mind when constructing them
are simplicity of use correctness of
code and accuracy of description
all complexes should be if possible be
buried
out of sight so yeah there is no need
for a routine there is no need for
refactoring code but because we are
communicating between
people we want to make sure they
understand what we solve in that
particular
problem and by the way this woman here
is a this is a picture from a book that
david wheeler
wrote because he wrote the first
programming book also
1956 maybe or earlier
and this is the first programmer ever
pictured
in a programming book so
there you go with your machitos are the
only ones
that are programming anyway
and if you read the the
[Applause]
text below look at the metaphors that
back then were not
metaphors she has a library of tapes
with the where the subroutines are
punched so that thing there that cabinet
was a library
an actual library of routines which was
like some paper thing that they would
punch into the machine i don't even know
so
everything we talk is metaphorical in a
way
you will see more later but
metaphors and code
in code i say that types
are the characters that tell the story
of our programs
but for the haskell people that is
cheering in behind
chillax because i'm not talking about
those types
it's types as in programming with astra
data types by barbara
liskov barbara liskov had to fight
you know all this well actually that we
have today on twitter if
it was twitter times barbara alisko was
full of those
telling her that you don't need
uh extra data types that attraction was
wrong
because uh they were already
in the post war of uh
go-to and they managed to move out away
from go to 1964 and so on
so in 1974 she came but we also can do
abstraction
and people were all fighting against her
ideas
but the problem is is that we if we
don't have types we just have operations
on a stream of mice
so let's talk about choosing the the
right data structure
we have a problem where we need for
example to count or to keep somewhere
all
the people that came to cs conf eu
you can use an array that will work
perfectly you can just
put every everybody inside there fine
but if you use a set that metaphor that
has a very specific meaning in
mathematics
is telling you that that bunch of
whatever it is in this case of users
those users have to be unique so just by
changing the data type you are telling
me a lot of information
about how you solve your program if you
use a linked list you are telling me you
can traverse this in this way but you
cannot do inserts however you want
if you have a queue you are telling me
first thing first out
stack the reverse operation
because a program explanatory power
is a measure of its own elegance
if your program cannot explain what
you're trying to do
not sure we satisfy the the initial goal
and data structures they have
explanatory power
that can give us a cognitive leaps
for example tax scheduling we want
uh to be able to serve food based on the
order in which people arrive
at the counter and plan if their country
is full
maybe we need to bring another person to
too boring
but if we start talking about queuing
theory if we understand this is a
problem in queueing theory
not only we have a bunch of of language
to talk about that problem
there's a whole theory of queuing
that was developed by erlang back in the
30s i think for
telecommunications and we can base our
analysis of the problem
on actual mathematical theory the same
here how do i get from here to tegel
airport
number one don't take the bus but
you can try to guess and and try many
things
but at some point you will know you have
a graph
theory problem here
and with there you have all the
mathematics to solve this
and by the way not only that map is not
a map
of the territory if you have heard that
sentence
the graph is a metaphor of that
territory
and that graph is enable you to do
things
with the territory and also it's
forbidding you to do things with the
territory
so that metaphor of the graph in graph
theory and maps
is is what i was saying before it has
explanatory power
it has constraining powers but i think
the most interesting example
comes from the replication from database
replication
they tried to build an algorithm to
spread data using rumor
rumor mongering basically
i have i'm a computer i have some data i
say to this computer and this other
computer
then this computer spread the rumor to
other two computers and so on
like in a latin american telenovela the
same way to spread rumors
so this is the way we understand the
world
so the problem is
it's really easy to explain with this
metaphor
but it's really hard to reason about the
correctness of
of the algorithms but they saw
that
[Music]
this also mapped what's the word mapped
to epidemics and in epidemics there is a
book which is the mathematical theory of
epidemic from the
40s or 50s so they can use all the math
in that book
to prove that their algorithm will
spread the data to all the nodes doing
replication
because they understood another metaphor
the same way an epidemic goes through a
population is how
you can send data through a bunch of
nodes
and is everything a meta for them like
this is what you're trying to say
yes actually when i was watching this
film
i heard her saying metaphors be with you
because i was so into this
thing i said like did she really say
metaphor with you
yes she did so everything is a metaphor
i don't believe you
i just read one slide because i don't
have that much time but
this is distributed system literature
whenever
nodes needs to agree on a common value
we start a consensus
algorithm to decide on a value there's
usually a leader process
that takes care of making the final
decision based on the vote
it has received from its peers we send
messages on a channel channels get
congested that's too much traffic
we get bottlenecks and so on
we end up with network partitions
is a computer dead this is all
metaphorical language and there are more
metaphors there that i don't want to
bore you with
so yeah we when we don't know how to
explain something we use metaphorical
language
all the time and yes it is time
that we don't talk anymore about master
slave
take it out it's very very easy
anyway let's talk about passwords
and you know this one right um
containers i was wondering
why containers picked up so much but if
we took if we think about containers
like the actual physical container is a
standard thing
that can be shipped anywhere feed some
train ships and trucks
you can stack them you can reuse them
and so on
it's a very good language to speak about
this thing i'm trying to build
and i'm trying to sell you i also wonder
if at some point somebody will be
having a startup to recover wreckage
from shipping containers i don't know
but another password
is micro services when i read this blog
post they say decentralized governance
monolith versus microservice isolation
collaboration
small is better biggest cumbersome david
versus gold yeah whatever
when i read the whole blog post and say
but this is ellen
second paragraph this is erlang next
paragraph this is erlang
i don't know if any of you here works in
ireland
but i was like wow these guys literally
stole everything from erlang and gave
them a new name
in the very last paragraph on the
footnotes it says
in another direction one could argue
that microservices are the same thing as
the lm programming model
but applied to an enterprise application
context so are you crying little lamb
boy because i don't use erlang no i'm
not crying my question is
what is erlang elevator speech these
are the metaphors in ireland kill
children
you stone children you have
on those children and the actor model
what is even the actor model so imagine
trying to sell airline with this kind of
vocabulary
very hard so first
get people to understand things then
explain how things actually
work for example israelite mq
a job server i was a rabbit nq core
developer also developer advocate
when people ask me this question i will
say no it isn't rabbit mq is a q
server a message is much a higher
abstraction than jobs you can also do
jobs and like
okay do shut up it is a job server yes
understand rabbit with that metaphor and
then we can go
deeper and try to see what it actually
is
conclusion we need to master the art of
metaphor
selection we need to master the art of
meaning amplification
and finally our program is a metaphor
for the solution
we found
if you want references some of the books
i read
some of the pictures i stole from the
internet and
thank you very much
yes one more thing i want to say thanks
to the organizers because it's not often
that you see a conference where latinos
are not only serving food
latinos are speaking latinos are there
in the crowd so thanks